good
evening
and welcome to the central area planning
committee at Malden District Council
today Thursday the 19th of October 2020.
I'm councilor Carly Mays and I'm your
chairman this evening
members and officers during the IH item
please indicate if you would like to
speak I'll then invite you at the
appropriate time and if you couldn't
make sure that you turn your microphones
on and off so that the recordings are
nice and clear that would be appreciated
thank you
uh burner do we have any apologies
I didn't count everybody hi that's
brilliant
um okay let's move to item three
um and it is recommended that the
minutes of the meeting for the central
area planning committee held on the 27th
of July are approved as an accurate
record these are for only for accuracy
um ISO move do I have a seconder thank
you Flo
Declarations of Interest
members are reminded that they are
required to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other registerable interests
and non-registerable interests relating
to any items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph 9 and XB of
the code of conduct for members
you're also reminded to disclose any of
these at such times as you become aware
of them should the need arise
does anybody have anything to declare
no
nice and simple burner
so far so good
uh right we now move to item
um five and item six
uh well I'm actually going to swap these
round and I'm going to take item six
first
um for
the
um a single story rare extension so I'm
going to take that one first and then
we're going to look at the annex
okay if that's okay with that is
everybody happy with that
yeah okay
yes I just just wondered why
um I think as we progress through the
potential is we know what both things
are on the table
um the potential is to either refuse or
approve both or neither and I think that
this way around would be a better way
around
um to actually proceed okay thank you
thank you
okay
um is that okay Nicola yes lovely thank
you
um
item uh six six is
um
application
220672 27 London Road found on pages 25
to 32. it's a proposal for a single
story uh rear extension the application
has come before this committee as Mr
Drummond is a member of staff
the officer who is looking after this
case is Miss Ward
um and I will invite her to make her
presentation now
thank you Nicola thank you chair
so uh
this is the application site and the
extension is to be here to the rear of
the application site
um next to and joining an existing
extension that was built under permitted
development back in 2017.
this is the block plan that shows the
layout the extension is to accommodate
an Annex for the applicants parents and
it would provide a communal living space
to the rear a a bathroom and a bedroom
area
this is the existing floor plan
and the existing first floor plan that
is to be unaltered
and this shows the arrangements of the
bedroom the ensuite area and then the
communal living room to be used by all
the occupants of the dwelling
so the existing the existing extension
that's put was built back in 2017.
the elevations that show the proposed
extension the post extension will
measure approximately eight meters in
depth
um and uh would be approximately one at
3.7 meters in height so this these
pictures are the site pictures that show
you the existing extension here and the
location of the proposed extension would
run along this section here I believe
that
some of these I haven't got it uh
confirmed however I believe that
um this outbuilding will be demolished
to accommodate the extension and the
extension would sit along an exit
adjacent to the neighboring
um lean to extension here and project a
further
approximately five meters beyond the
neighboring extension there is concerns
with regards to the scale and the bulk
of the extension and due to this the
impact that that would then have on that
neighboring occupier to the north of the
site here and therefore the officer's
recommendation is refusal thank you
chair
thank you Nicola
um members I now open it for debate uh
and invite to put any questions
councilor Nunn thank you chair
um so I was a bit confused about why
these were two separate applications
am I picking up from your suggestion
about the way we're dealing with this
that if one's approved the other one's
not required
that is my understanding
um Mr Mrs Ward are you able to elaborate
at all uh from my understanding thank
you chair
um that it is meant to be an alternative
um situation that both would not
necessarily be um constructed however if
both were approved they would have the
option to build both
thank you thank you
um any other questions
councilor Swain
thank you
yes
um
this is this is what one would normally
think of as an Annex
um and meets um all the various criteria
that uh are listed as appropriate to an
Annex it's not too big and so on
um scale design and appearance scale
design and appearance or considered to
be okay
um
and it is clearly subservient or
subordinate as the phase goes to the
main building as far as I can see
um this issue of whether it um is
unnably
um impacts on the number 25 I think it
is 29 29 the other way
um seems to be the only 25 oh I've got
another one immediately joining property
which has got a an extension part way so
this would go a bit further than that
this seems to be the only argument
against this particular application
um and bearing in mind the length of
these Gardens the extra distance
um the extra length doesn't seem to me
um all that significant I agree it would
be and therefore less of an impact on
the neighboring property
um and
um I don't know if the officer can
actually show more clearly
how it would relate to the neighboring
property
but it were the extension to to go up
perhaps it's a case of looking at the
that side of the property and the
if you've got an image of that side of
the property and the neighbor's
extension
yes Mr Johnson yeah um
the bottom the bottom drawing shows a
relationship
um looking yourself
so what so the this is a sort of gray
bit in the front if you want to point
out that's that's the neighboring
property
and we can see the relationship with the
proposed extension it's quite a long yes
and um just to give you some I mean I'm
sure members are all very familiar with
but I I tend to try and think of things
in real life if we're looking at
something which is about three meters by
five meters you're looking at something
to scale of this wall here
to sort of give some sort of perspective
and the issue is the proximity to the
rear rear-facing window in number 25.
thank you chairman thank you Mr Johnson
uh councilor uh heard
um thank you Jim I know that no letters
of representation have been received
about this may we just see the
photographs again please just showing
the rear garden and uh so there seems to
be some
buildings
already down that side
and some of those will be removed my
understanding is is that correct that's
correct yes right okay so it's a single
story rear extension
um I'd personally I don't have a problem
with it
thank you uh thank you my only comment
uh sorry councilor Beal No my only
comment was
um if if you look at the the photograph
or at the bottom left with the awning
thing with the parasol thing so the
extension would come out to probably at
least the one the second panel along
not quite I don't think it'll come out
quite as far as that but certainly the
second one along
um
no if you go to the bottom bottom left
you have that one and then go so you've
got there's there's one panel and you go
to the next panel yeah it's going to
come to at least there
um from from the building
which is it's about five meters from the
end
because it's eight meters from the edge
of their house
it's quite a long way out
um and would you or I like to look at a
brick wall
out of our window it's just a comment
um
going forward that's just my my view
um councilor Beale
thank you chairman I mean basically
those pictures don't really show you
squiggly dick I mean it's hard to
understand where where the actual things
go in I can understand the 24 odd for
and I can understand the practicality of
having it attached to the property
because then you haven't got the issue
of oh you can use that as a separate
dwelling
um but as I said it is big
um and it is attached to the house
but they do also understand the length
of that wall on the neighboring property
but I don't think it's going to cause
overshadow
East no it won't no I mean I wouldn't
call shadowing would it
sorry I was going to say that in the
report it actually says at 5.3 and 5.
sorry 5.3.3 that there's not significant
impact on sunlight so yeah I think I
think the way that the Sun comes round
um that that wouldn't be as huge impact
as possibly if it was a different
orientation sorry
um language I I was going to say that
but in addition to
um
it's sort of been uh the visual impact
it's over it's it's overbearing this
it's how one feels
um an extra structure that you you sort
of feel dwarfed and engulfed by so
there's also that sort of
how you feel about being in a space a
space that you live in particular
um there is yeah as as councilor may
have pointed out that there isn't a a
sunlight and an overshadowing issue
thank you Jim
um I'll come back to you councilor sway
sorry did you want to come back yeah
yeah please
um as I said so it's not the only issue
really is that that little window from
the next door neighbor
[Music]
um
I don't know it's a hard one I mean I
know it's 24 foot on the back of but I
mean is that existing extension going to
be left there or is it going to go from
where the cream wall is uh it actually
goes from from the cream wall yeah so
that's coming down yeah
this is to remain
so you're going to extend on on that
extension yeah not on the back of the
house
no it's actually filling in the Gap if
you look you can see in the top one
there's a gap between the where the
cream wall is and the extension that's
coming out the additional piece of
extension is going to come out from
there because it's an L shape isn't it
yes
does that make sense okay
um
no it no it's on
uh councilor stilts then councilor Swain
and then um
is the same slide package you sent us
can you put up slide four because I
think that's going to show an awful lot
that one
so from what I can see there that dark
gray part where your cursor is that is
the neighbor's wall
and then the extension is the bit that
goes on beyond that and then you can see
it fills in the gap between the existing
extension that's already there
is that correct yeah thank you
uh
councilor Lagoon and then I'll come back
to council's fine thank you thank you
chair
um I could agree with uh with Mr Johnson
I know the area very well I grew up down
there and the size of the extension is
is rather large indeed and would would
be overbearing in the reasons for
refusal were quite clear because of the
size there's nothing in that road it's a
very nice house it's been it's been
renovated and extended very very
carefully but this is something that
doesn't fit in that our area that the
gardens are very long they have good
space in the front and also at the back
and one of the things that causes me a
little bit of concern is when the back
road was put in at the back of London
Road in Fitch's Crescent many years ago
when I was shows how old it was I was a
little little boy that the concept of
that was so that people could actually
have a rear garden access for parking
um I don't know if that has anything to
do with it we may have to look at
something like that but I think it
wouldn't it's not within keeping within
the street scene there and it is very
overbearing in its current form
okay thank you
um councilor Swain
thank you chairman can we go back to
that one which was put up to make this
um point about being overbearing just
that way
um
yes I mean the measurement
um it's 200 two and a half meters at the
eaves isn't it that's the height yes two
and a half meters and
3.7 to the
um top of the roof that uh that seems to
me that the diagram seems to me to give
a false impression of how big it is or
how high it is
um
I mean if I don't know if this
measurement is quite accurate I can't
recall
because that that measurement says
3.05 doesn't it there's 3.05 yes so
that's three meters which is even more I
mean that's more than this that's quite
high if I was sitting in a lounge chair
and looking at potentially five meters
of that going out from the end of my
lean to Conservatory
on the at number 25.
and the we believe that the window
actually serves a living room that's
what we that's what we believe in it
would be 0.5 meters from the boundary of
of the existing neighboring extension
um
a council herd
I propose we agree the recommendation
do I have a
second body in agreement
to refuse to yes to go with the officer
recommendation to refuse the application
can I have a show of hands please
I think that's unanimous thank you
thank you very much
um we'll now return to item five going
backwards
um and this is our next
um are going the application has come
before us uh as the applicant is a
member of staff
Mrs Ward could you
do your presentation please
thank you chair the application is for a
single story detached Linux uh to the
rear of the application site
uh the AmEx would be located
approximately 12 meters from the closest
point of the main house and would
accommodate a living area a bathroom a
kitchen and a bedroom
and would be again for the applicant's
parents
the overall height would be four meters
of the building of the outbuilding
and the existing outbuildings here would
all be removed to accommodate the air
the new outbuilding
and these are some of the outbuildings
that are within the area so this
outbuilding here that we can see which
is one of the Neighbors which is quite
high and I believe would actually sit
higher than the proposed out building
um
uh is is uh I believe two neighbors
along to the north so approximately uh
number 23 London Road uh and these out
buildings that you can see are actually
um across the access road at the back
Fitch's Crescent
to the east of the site uh the
application is recommended for approval
it meets all the requirements under the
policies
um and therefore is recommended for
approval
and thank you I'd like to open it up to
questions uh counselor non and then
councilor Spencer
um
can can the officer please explain to us
how under this this
um this planning application how under
5.1.3
it meets criteria two and five
okay
sorry was that 5.2.3
Criterion too and
five
bearing in mind the comparison that
we've been asked to look at this with
garden garden out buildings as opposed
to habitation
sorry I'm not quite sure
dysfunctional through YouTube yeah of
course for functional link
whereas the functional link with the
minds dwelling
the occupants so the and how is it
designed in a way that the annex could
then be used oh could you turn it yeah
sorry I missed that sorry thank you
thank you um thank you counselor Bill
very kind of you
um so um how how does the how does this
building have a functional link with the
main dwelling what's functional link
mean
um so is it not a physical link
and how will that Annex be used later
date as an integral part of the main
dwelling
when they're separate
so the functional link would be that
they have shared amenities for example
they would share the immediate private
menti space you know washing facilities
and meals could be taken in the main
house and they are all going to be and
they're all going to be linked out in
terms of family and dependency on the
occupants of the main house and the
outbuilding
um with regards to how it would then be
integrated into the main house if for
example the new owner was to take over
they could use it as an outbuilding for
a summer house or storage so it could
then be integrated and used as part of
the main dwelling and not necessarily
separated off as a separate dwelling
which is what we're looking at for that
particular functional link and obviously
in its of perpetuity and how it goes
forward and not necessarily for the
current occupiers but any future
occupiers of the dwelling can integrate
that outbuilding into their into to
their day-to-day requirements
confusing but grateful for the answer
thank you thank you um Mr Johnson did
you want to say did you want to add
anything uh no no not really it was just
miss water explained it fully I I I do
understand where councilor nuns come in
from it can
apologies yeah I do understand where
Council nuns coming from it can appear a
bit confusing in terms and I think
especially in the case where this where
you have
with the previous example something
which is actually part of the the
original building and then you have
something separate but the functional
link bit is is notional in the center
side it doesn't mean that it has to be
physically attached
um in a way
it could effectively just be an
outbuilding like any other album and
Miss more gave examples of how that
could be to which any one of us could
build under permitted development
subject to the criteria
um in this case it's because of the
particular use
there is a caring element there is a a
level of disability
there's that Reliance there's that link
with the occupants of the house which is
why it's important that there is that
relationship Link in a sense I mean we
have applications of All Sorts come like
this where people just say oh some
relative or some member of the family or
somebody might be sick in the future you
know these sorts of things and we don't
accept that argument uh in this
particular case the medical
documentation has been submitted to say
well this is what the ailment that the
person has it's an elderly person and
they are reliant on that person but at
the same time maintaining a level of
Independence
within the rounds of the house itself
thank you chairman thank you uh Council
spenceley
thank you chair
um
yes I I can really say that and I'm
really sympathetic to the needs of the
applicant however if we look at
5.1.7 it says it is considered due to
the detached out building being the rear
of the gut in the rear of the garden but
the outbuilding could be used at a later
date as an integral part of the main
dwelling for such things like Garden
storage or a summer house so I I get
what you're saying but I just my
question would be would it then be that
later on it couldn't be used by someone
else as a dwelling because it just seems
unlikely to me that something that's
sophisticated with a kitchen and and a
bathroom is going to be used for garden
storage I find that a little bit forgive
me but unlikely so would we then put a
condition on that would say that it
couldn't be used later because that also
seems quite bizarre so I just it's just
the clarity around that I wanted to be
sure of thank you
Mr Johnson
thank you chairman again I understand
that this
this is an issue that's kind of
medieval's planning for decades I have
to admit I've been involved in this for
for decades there's been numerous appeal
decisions around this which have swung
one way or the other the consensus that
it seems to have come to now and I've
worked in many authorities where this
very same issue always comes up uh what
happens after that need doesn't appear
to be in existence you know
unfortunately in life people pass on
that sort of thing
um what happens to it then
the main purpose for planning in terms
of our land use planning is to ensure
that the the building does not become a
separate dwelling yeah that's the main
thing and attached to this is a
condition to say it should not be used
as a separate Direction which is
conditioned for
um
yeah it is sophisticated some people
will put in a higher level of
accommodation than others some don't
have kitchen some just may have a little
kitchenette just a microwave I know
something like that
um
it could be used by another family
member that may well be the case another
need for a particular ailment dependence
requirement may also come up again but
the main thing is integral to that
dwelling it's not separated from the
dwelling which again within the criteria
there's things like they shouldn't it
shouldn't have its own garden or it'd be
separated by fencing and things of that
nature
um and that's kind of the position in
the planning world where it is in terms
of that
thank you uh cancer bail thank you so
that that was really my question I
wanted to make sure that there was a
condition in there that it couldn't be
used as a separate living accommodation
and as for that nonsense I mean I don't
know where he got that one from there's
no way in Hell's Earth that's going to
be a shed for a whatever
I mean if it is I'll move
um
at the end of the day I just want to
make sure there's a condition that it
can't be used in existing and it can't
be any dividing fence from the existing
property so they can get access from the
rear
yes because there is rare access there
is rear access here just as a matter of
interest does the uh Annex uh go from
boundary to boundary side boundary to
side boundary
is there any space
that there is yeah
there is approximately just over a meter
here which is to the south of the site
and just under a meter here to the north
of the site
and I don't know what that distance is
1.1 is that one oh yeah I seem to
remember yeah I think it was Council
Bill sorry it's just reminded me why
haven't we got um some sort of plan
showing where that building's going to
be or this plan does
um if you see the red lines on either
side they're the boundary lines yeah
um and then where is that right back
against The Back Fence
um no it's about
it's about me that's what I'm saying I
haven't got a little block pen that says
oh it's halfway up the Garden or it's
down the other end no I think it's a
meter from the bottom fence
of that side yeah
so does he come drive a car down a meter
does it come with compultery umbrellas
and
Maybe
um councilor Swain okay
um chairman we not only have a rather
strained interpretation of functional
but it was now of integration
two things firstly
it's hardly an Annex if it's so far
apart from the house I mean it's um
another upstretched term it is a
separate and seemingly self-contained
site and the other thing is we
if we're looking at it and strictly in
planning terms we're supposed to ignore
the personal circumstances of the of the
particular applicant because the
um
situation would change and anybody
coming into it subsequently would either
feel constrained by having this
additional property
um at the back of their Garden
or might make use of it in a way which
they're not supposed to I mean those
properties along the back that have all
got accesses at the back and it wouldn't
wouldn't be long before gate was put in
The Back Fence for Access
um
so
um
I
I can't see this really fulfills the
criteria for being a
a
subservient and part of the
um the dwelling never would be
um
so I I can't really accept the arguments
for it thank you
would you like to elaborate
situation with extenuating circumstances
Mr Johnson
thank you chairman
um
the criteria we apply is encapsulated
within the specialist needs
um plan a document I'm sure I've missed
a word out there and that's where these
criterias come from under
um
there's policy H4
and when we was a section in the report
under 5.1.3 the criteria one to seven
that's directly lifted from The
Specialist
needs planning document that is what we
apply and and in particular it's about
that the the special circumstances
rather than just having it that anybody
can go in there so to speak
um we do have applications of that
type we've had applications considered
by other Committees of that type where
we've refused applications because they
are not able to demonstrate that but
they may have been approved a committee
so
it's one in which sometimes
unfortunately different interpretations
can be applied to it but we do apply the
criteria within our planning documents
thank you chairman thank you I'll go to
council heard and then I'll come back to
you councilor bail
yes thank you chairman yes I'm I'm
satisfied about the the positioning of
it uh I'm also satisfied that there
should be a walk around boundary around
the actual property I would like to ask
if we can impose a further condition
that there's no pedestrian
access at the rear as a condition
and the reason that that I say that is
because I'm I understand why it's being
built
uh to as an Annex
for the the occupants parents
um
and I think that condition four
does make it clear that it should be
used only for purposes incidental to the
residential use but I think that it
would be very tempting to rent that out
as a single
uh unit but I think if if there was a
condition that there was no access at
the rear uh that would deter it
[Applause]
Mr Johnson
because I have no idea yeah um thank you
chairman um
I I think I think a condition like that
could be a bit problematic for us in
terms of
um well whether it meets the test for
one
um and and a test includes you know is
it reasonable and that sort of thing and
even if we were to
I mean to all intents and purposes the
properties delayed dwelling house which
will still carries permitted development
rights
um
if one
if they remove the existing gate
there's nothing to stop them from
putting another one in under permitted
development unless you wants to get into
moving removing permitted development
rights it starts getting a bit messy and
probably difficult that and if there was
a challenge or an appeal on these
conditions it may be a bit awkward for
us to defend it
and if it's considered unreasonable
there could be costs involved
we do think that the that the condition
is the condition which is one widely
used up and down the country in appeal
decisions and and I for one to spend a
lot of my time reading appeal decisions
to see what goes on in other authorities
um and you know and inspectors and you
know everybody refers on appeal
decisions in all different places in a
way that are they taking the right route
with these things
um
I mean I would even say over the over
the years I've swung different ways
because that's how it's been but this is
the standard position we've even had a
pure a number of appeal decisions on
these things recently in Malden
um and the conditions that we've
attached are the robust ones and seemed
to satisfy what's required thank you
chairman thank you thank you Miss
Johnson um Council Bill thank you chair
I'm obviously on a roll tonight it was
unusual
um
I think what councilor heard is a very
valid point so I don't think it is an
issue I know if I was an officer at NDC
I would be asking fellow officers what I
can and can't do
is that a back gate top right hand
corner on that right hand side of the
picture
yeah
so
so it could go either one of two ways it
could either be yes a very good selling
point because my parents and and us are
going to buy this house knowing they've
got somewhere to live right that's the
first option
but a more likely option is they will
let that out
as a second property because you've got
rear access
so I think that's a very valid point
because you've got that back gate
leading out onto that whatever it is
Road Track or whatever it's about it's a
proper service road it's a yeah
but you can guarantee that'll either go
that allowed to be a good selling point
when they sell it so that grandparents
and children live together that's the
plus but the minus is that's got a back
gate and that means that someone could
use that as a separate entity to the
property
as another form of income especially
with the cost of living as it is at the
minute so I would like to see that back
gain taken out
I think Mr Johnson's made it quite clear
that that would not be I think
reasonable or
um even
um enforceable going forward so you
think if they did use it as a rented
property
that someone's going to come out and say
oh do you know they're using that as a
rented property
isn't going to check on that then it
comes down to enforcement doesn't it
because we have got a a condition that
says that it has to be used as
incidental residential use so that would
be another addition to the 385 pages of
the enforcement
I hear what you're saying and you lose
the will to liver after page 100 yeah
yeah and I've not even reached my world
I think that is a big mistake having
that back gate in there because that
could be open to different options
uh I'll come to you in just a moment
Miss Johnson no thank you I mean I I
mean I've made my point But ultimately
you know decisions here are within
members gifts
if we put a condition in
um it could be appealed
so and we could lose so that um
whatever the thing I'm for you said is
in the conditions
is it cannot be a separate dwelling yes
outside of the family yes
but I'm not happy about that back gate
but
yeah I think counselors
uh councilor heard thank you really just
uh I was only exploring the possibility
about the gate but I'm satisfied from Mr
Johnson's answer uh that uh that
condition four
um is strong enough
um to deter anything like that so I'm
happy with that
and
I'm happy to come back with a proposal
if I can
can I counselor Edwards first I propose
that we accept the office of
recommendation please
do I have a
views on this uh cancerous Swain if you
could make it because it is just a brief
additional comment
um if this
um goes through it does make this a
completely different property from the
point of view of future occupants it is
now a completely different proposition
it's not just a house with an Annex tact
on or built on as the previous
um application application would have
been if it had been slightly modified or
slightly less dominant
um this is this is now a completely
different animal
thank you
I'll go back to uh councilor Edwards has
um
okay all those in favor could I have a
show of hands please
one
two three four five six seven eight
four those against
two against any abstentions just me
burner
okay that's that's carried thank you
this is Mrs wall do you want to stay or
would you like to go
no I don't want to go that's why I'm
asking you I know you've got small
children
okay
members
um let's now move to item seven
um before we look at item seven
um which is application
2200820 Promenade Park Park Drive Malden
um
property belonging to and controlled by
modern District Council who is the
applicant I'd like to just make a
comment
um
I would like this matter deferred
and sent to uh strategy and resources
committee to look at this much more
closely before it comes back to planning
for decision making
do I have anybody who would second my
proposal
thank you
um Miss councilman what did you want to
say something I uh you're reading my
mind well I don't know about that
for me with this application something
uh fundamental is missing and it's
something that we've been promised for
months
which is a plan for the prom
now before Mr Johnson tells me that's
not a planning issue no um this is our
application submitted by Malden District
Council for consideration by modern
District Council I can't imagine any
developer
putting forward a speculative planning
application without having some forward
plan about what they're trying to
achieve
and I just think this is a completely ad
hoc misplace application that needs to
be in context before it's submitted so I
would certainly second your proposal to
have it deferred thank you before I go
to a vote I'm going to go to councilor
Lagan then I'll come to councilor Swain
and then cancel a bill
yeah thank you I think um although the
proposed was a sound proposal I think
they did the items should be debated
because it has been called in
um by councilor Swain and I think that
if we could look at the debate and see
what members feel about the report and
the objectives of the report and then
see if the vote is takes it for or
against and then a proposal for them to
go to strategy and resources could be a
meaningful proposal because I think
there's some considerations that should
be debated by members this evening with
the content of the report as it stands
and it has been called in by a award
member as well yeah I it would come to
um committee anyway
um because it is uh one of our own
applications so thank you councilor
Lagan councilman Swain
um yes
um perhaps um Miss Matthews or Mr
Johnson we can give some guidance here
but we are we are looking at how we're
being asked to look at this as a
planning issue
um and therefore we have to not
um infiltrate
um other matters of policy concerning
usage of the problem Park
um that there were two points from a
planning Point well it's difficult to
disentangle them and I'm not necessarily
going against what you're recommending
but
um perhaps the officers could explain
why this is necessary
given the um
operational scope for officers to
actually use these areas for the
purposes that are identified in the
application
could you ask the question again just to
make sure I understand
the district council need planning
permission to do what they can probably
do anyway
conservation
um
I was if I'm being totally honest I was
wondering as I was driving here I was
thinking the same thing
um but um sometimes
um
I mean that we have had applications for
similar things but it's been which have
been submitted by Third parties our
businesses who want to operate from from
within the park
um so uh so we have had applications
similar but that the applicants have
been businesses rather than the council
itself
um
sometimes councils want to be open and
transparent and want wanted to make sure
that the public have had an opportunity
to comment on proposals um even if
strictly speaking they could possibly
use their rights to go ahead and do it
anyway
um I have seen applications made on that
basis in the past not necessarily here
but um in other places
um
but
um it's not it's not an application I've
had any dealings with prior to it being
submitted it was submitted so I've I've
dealt with it but um
yeah so and and that but that's all all
I know but that the council does have
rights to do certain things in the park
and the planning unit
I mean I mean it is quite a quite a
number of sites within the park so it
might have felt that that in total it
was it was too much to just to go ahead
and do
um on the back of um the the counselor
as function as
um you know managing and operating the
park as a related facility
um but a valid question and I don't
really have an answer I'm afraid
um but um one can be found I'm sure but
not the people I need to ask aren't on
here that thank you
um councilor Beale
hopefully I haven't forgot half of what
I was going to ask
um
I think the explanation I can give is if
it's a I totally concur with councilor
none you know we were supposed to be
having an idea of what was going to
happen and what why we were doing what
we were going to do what we're going to
achieve out of it financially Etc but I
think the reason it's come to planning
is the fact that where it's a one-off
like a concert or something then the
officers have got the power to do that
but this is more of a semi permanent as
in I don't know how many months it is
wrong time of day to be doing maths but
basically it's August September is it
about six six months yeah so half the
year you know it's going to be used for
that and it's going to be a permanent
thing it's not just going to be like a
one-off for a concert and then not next
year this is going to be a permanent
every six months of the year so I think
that's the reason why it's come to
council and one
um so I think councilman's right that we
do need some sort of idea of what sort
of thing we're looking at and why and do
we need it Etc and also I'd remind
members
but you do need after counselor no not
counselor I'm promoting him already uh
the solicitor Mr quelch
I can't call him squelch can I quelch
um yeah he he recommended that we get a
dispensation so if you haven't got a
dispensation for an application that
we're actually putting in you're not
able to vote
um
yeah thank you burner thank you okay
thank you Council bill um can I go to
councilor heard then councilor stilt and
then councilor Lagan
yes thank you chairman I I suspect one
of these uh applications will be for a
motorized ice cream van uh which is uh
going all day uh
at the uh
one of the locations yeah one of those
um what I'd like to do I mean I agree
that this should be referred to another
committee but I can't see anything in
this report about air quality and I
would like the the committee to consider
a motorized vehicle
emitting diesel fumes all day whilst
it's serving ice cream right where the
children are playing so I would like
that report included thank you thank you
councilor stilts and thank you manager I
agree with councilor herdy in that
um I must admit I looked at this and
thought this is in retrospect because we
already have a shepherd's hat reading
room we already have a lady that does
painting at the van which is parked down
by the Walter's Edge we already have the
ice cream van so what is different in
this and I agree with councilor Nunn and
yourself that where is the actual plan
for this park is this for more
concessions of the same we already have
the bar although it's not called The
Grape and Grain bar
so I can't understand
why this has come to us and he's not
retrospective because we've had this for
quite a while down there at least two
years thank you
um
councilor Lagann
sorry yeah I think that the obviously
the way the conversation's going to
debate it sounds like a deferral to
strategy resources made sense but I
think there's a couple of things that we
need to consider that the activities
that are carried out on the prom now are
under the 28-day rule where this is
looking for a sixth month extension to
that for more permanent
um uh I can't call them attractions from
what I saw from the photographs
I find them very
unin keeping with the Promenade Park if
you look at the recent development Mr
Salisbury the
um rossies and all of those places
they're very much within keeping and
these these certainly are not so I think
that does need a that deep diving look
second council9 is exactly right from
the central area master plan project 16
talks about the prom management part so
you cannot put this application forward
through with any justification to say
that it fits that in the report it
actually dictates that they would go
some way to support the visitors in a
center in the restaurant that's not
actually correct because in the
sanctuary master plan they call for a
restaurant and a visitor center not for
these These are
to regularize what we already have well
it's there's 10 days there's ten
concessions on there already this this
would add another seven so that would be
17 concessions this is a commercial grab
for money
that's what it is and the fundamental
aspect of of which I would like to have
debated the the report because there's
some fundamental flaws it's not policy
compliant for many policies when we look
at policies in one policy N3 policy and
5 s1d1
um there's there's against the mppf it
it's not it does not sit whatsoever it
doesn't sit with any of those so I think
that the the deferral to
um to the the committee
um to look at it because where's the
business case to justify what it can
bring because also the ecology
um Consultants that that did a report
said it would improve uh footfall
to the to the town
um there's there's a lot of no
disrespect to them it's nice little
report but there's a lot of fundamental
areas here and I'm not against
additional things coming on the prom
you know it's just got to be in the
right place with the right feel to be
able to support the visitor attraction
but the fundamental aspect of it is
there's a central area master plan
that's been passed by the council which
we have to adhere to we have that drum
downers so many times and also I am
highly disappointed that we as members
weren't consulted and talked to about
the different areas because I have my
right foot run over by a little boy with
a remote control down there two weeks
ago in the amphitheater
um and it was so sweet the way that he
did it and you're taking that away by
putting a concession in there so you're
actually it needs a bit more of a
strategic thought and I think the master
plan and the prompt part management plan
which Mr Holmes has promised to Taylor
for us would be the place to start and
then you start to look at what do we
need to do to be able to bring more
attractions these are not attractions
the tents Shepherd's Huts they're not
problems
so I think there's a lot to a lot to do
I would very much support councilman and
your you will reckon thank you
um I'll come to you in just a moment
councilor Swain I'm going to go check
out suspensely first because she hasn't
spoken just to say really to agree with
a lot of what's already been said by
other members um I don't feel that this
is the right
committee for this this item at the
moment whether or not it needs
um planning permission eventually is
kind of irrelevant I think that there
are a whole lots of strategy matters
here and and things which aren't
appropriate for this committee before
they're discussed and for that reason I
absolutely support your um proposal that
it's deferred thank you
um councilor Swain could I ask you to
counselor her could ask you to turn your
thank you Malachi thank you Jim
um yes I just had that it is
um as we say um at the wrong time
um
[Music]
and um in the absence of
some general plans for managing the park
and for the approach the park we would
probably be having to add in so many
conditions to the use it would um uh
probably initiate the health purpose of
the proponents of this application
thank you okay
um I'd like to return to my original
proposal to defer this matter
I've had a second I've got a third or as
well could I could I have um um a vote
uh for approval by show of hands please
resolution it does not make any mention
of other committees
okay um in that case
um I will amend my proposal and send it
to full Council
so I'm happy to up happy to hold on a
second thank you councilor Lagan who in
that case um chair why can't we actually
open the debate
have the debate make a determination and
then it either stands or it falls
it's probably the easiest and clearest
way then there's no deferral to another
committee
oh we don't need to go for Council
really does it because at the end of the
day this committee can make a
determination I'm going to withdraw all
my
um proposals at this point do I have a
proposal from the floor cancer Lagoon
sorry I just need to put my glasses on
because I've hit that certain age
I recommend
should we not have to debate first the
presentation then the debate and then
is that the right the right form to be
honest yes
um I think my understanding of what
members concerned about is that really
um the council hasn't made a case for
the need for these extra concessions
within the prom Park and so it sounds to
me like members are concerned about the
principle of introducing these extra
concessions without proper justification
or or um explanation or I know in The
Wider context you know the the plan for
the park so so to me it sounds like
members are concerned about the
principle of it and that is that is a
relevant planning consideration so if
members feel that their the case hasn't
been made for these concessions then
that is a reason for refusal and under
planning grounds and you mentioned the
central area master plan and and yeah so
so I know it's been recommended for
approval and I'm talking against my own
recommendation but but um but so perhaps
now as as burner has said
um there's no real Avenue for referring
it to the strategy committee but I think
what members are perhaps saying in
another way is that that the council
hasn't made a proper case for this and
there are concerns about it and issues
have been raised about what it looks
like so there's character and parents
reasons there
um
um
issues have been made about pollution
but I think that's probably perhaps a
bit beyond material planning
considerations that's perhaps more more
of an issue for the council as a
landowner and giving out these leases
and permissions for these um sessions to
operate and which ones they choose to
allow and which ones they don't as a
landowner so it is a bit complicated and
difficult because we've got modern
Council as planning Authority and we've
got modern Council as landowner and and
manager and operator of of the park so
be careful to keep those two issues
separate but um to me it still feels
like there are material planning
situations that have been raised
potentially validly
um and that um
um it seems to me anyway that the
application could still be determined
today tonight
um
um and maybe it's it's one that that
because of concerns that have erased it
it's it's refused rather than rather
than approved or or it's deferred for
further justification to be provided
before you'll make your decision if if
that no so there is two options there I
think and which perhaps cover
cover the the original
um proposal but perhaps in slightly
differently thank you counselor
councilor Lagan I'll come back to you in
a moment just burner hold on wait a
burner a burner
[Music]
from all area of planning commissions
there is an issue that there's something
outstanding in our abroad
thank you uh I'll go to councilor um
none and then back to councilor Lagann
so if I mean I'm very grateful to Miss
Matthews for
um that advice
um if we refuse this tonight does that
mean that it will not be able to come
back to this committee for six months
if it's refused tonight
um the council could make to make
another application but that that's an
eight-week process
um no normally thank you so eight weeks
so
um
what's going around in my head at the
moment chair for what it's worth is
either a refusal or a
deferral
for more information got more
information being the Promenade plan
so I I would Rec so my recommendation
would be to defer it
for further information that further
information being the Promenade plan
thank you councilor Lagoon
yeah I know ideally what my colleague
says I I feel that there is a there's an
active planning application in front of
us and there are concerns in there and
they could all be part of that
um
to my mind if if members debate this
this evening and uh this is what this is
a central area plan and um this is that
committee thus it should be discussed at
this juncture if it is members wishes
that it's it's refused then it's only
eight weeks and then the officers will
know the valid reasons for for refusal
or acceptance if it goes that way and
then another application will be put in
but it will be very difficult I'd expect
for that application to happen without
the prom management plan and being an
overriding document in the hierarchy
there
okay
um before I go any further councilor
hubner did you want to yeah
we don't know why they're doing it okay
and how much money they're going to
generate and is there any benefit for
this
um
what I'd like to do if with the members
approval he's actually asked Miss
Matthews to do her presentation have a
short debate
and then come back to whether or not we
are going to defer it
counts
yeah
presentation does it show pictures of
the sort of thing that they're gonna yes
it does because I've just seen pictures
yes it does that's a little piece can
you just confirm that's not the back
gate for the last application
sorry thank you thank you
Miss Matthews could you do your
presentation for us please
thank you thank you chairman
um
okay so this is an application for um
use of seven areas within the prom park
for concessions in temporary type
structures
um between the months of April and
October and between the hours of 10 a.m
and 10 p.m each day so these are the
locations which it's not that clear
unfortunately but this is the
amphitheater here to orientate yourself
and the lake they've got one two three
four five six and seven and two um in
the um
play area doesn't it yeah
so that's
shows the same thing really but perhaps
slightly clearer with the red areas I
identified
block plan again
um there would be one concession one
structure temperature within each area
now these are the examples that have
been provided as part of the application
as potential
um structures
and then these are some photos of the
they've been labeled a no letters
um I'm sure you'll know very familiar
with with the prom Park but
um so these are so that's the
amphitheater there and
um we've got the area next to the
toilets here and the Splash Park area
here so they're just
um ideas of where it might be
um yeah so the recommendation is is for
approval and before I um go just
conclude I just want to make sure that
members have noted that there is an
update from the strategy team
um setting out
um quite strong support for the proposal
and the benefits it would be for the um
for the area in their View and I've also
um today had an email from Essex County
Council ecology
um it's one of the consultations and
responses it's missing and they raise no
objection but do you recommend
conditions which could be imposed first
if members did
resolve to Grant permission today
um so having assessed the application
officers view that the principal could
be viewed to be acceptable and carriage
and parents it's acceptable even though
it's a Conservation Area
um local residents wouldn't be adversely
affected issues relating to highway
safety parking and flood risk and nature
conservation are all um felt to be
acceptable or no no harmful impact and
it is recommended for approval but for a
temporary three-year three-year period
with at Limited hours to those proposed
and for April to October only
um and and that's that's recommendation
that's made be amazed so but thank you
thank you Miss Matthews
um
I sit here with a um
design degree and
that would fail
um I will leave my comments at that
level does anybody else have any other
comments they would like to make
counselor spenceley then councilor
Shaughnessy councilor Lagann right so I
probably need to declare an interest
first time I've ever done this I'm a
trustee of the modern Festival which I
think might be relevant to what I'm
about to say but it's a non-pecuniary
interest thank you
um
so
could someone just confirm for me with
regard to the unip plan for the amphi
theater would this then effectively
um rule out the opportunity much of the
time for open air performance
and through you chairman the um the
position of the of the one in in the
Arid Amphitheater has has been shown to
be here so it's outside the circular
area and the the um the amphitheater
itself is just a one one side
sorry
um is that
do you want to come back no
um
yes it's hard to say isn't it from just
looking at it like that and that I think
illustrates one of my just one of my
concerns in that it's not really clear
what the plan is and what we're planning
to do with the park and I do believe
that at some point in the past open air
performance was something that was
sometimes happened in fact I think there
was some Shakespeare there at one point
yeah
um and um it would be beautiful post
pandemic to see those things happening
again and I have some concerns with that
location that might make that quite
difficult even where it is and I think
we just we could be you know ruling out
things here for the future that we
haven't considered and so this is one of
the reasons why we don't have enough
information thank you thank you uh
Council Sean want to say
thank you chair
um yes I also have concerns with the one
proposed for the amphitheater I think
the amphitheater
um I agree with Council Lagan should be
left clear at all times
um the kiddies do love to play there run
around there you know and I don't think
there should be one there I also have
concerns about these engines running
um you know there are some
um in the uh prom anyway we don't need
to add to that
um being you know seeing as you know
everyone needs to be concerned about
climate change at the moment we do not
need extra CO2 floating around the um
the prom and as councilor heard said
particularly near the children's play
areas thank you very much thank you
councilor Lagoon I think I won't go over
all of the points and I agree with
councilor heard
um and the cancer Sean received but
there's when we was always told about
looking at policies and reasons because
it's not just the fact that you don't
particularly like the fact that it's a
shed but if you look at the policies
um you do take you know paragraph one in
the policy M1 of course for open spaces
for historic interests will be protected
so that's actually in our policy policy
one N4 says all developments must be
accompanied by a long-term management
plan to the council satisfaction so that
underlines and rubber stamps why we need
the prom Park management plan first of
all before we do anything else
then in policy our own policy section N3
6.21 it says National policy plans to
protect Open Spaces that's page 105 of
our own local development plan and under
6.22 of M3 it talks to councils
committed to protecting and maintaining
existing um and informal Open Spaces
there's only a couple more this is this
is why I was concerned about the the the
plan as it comes forward to us are there
it's in a 623 the council generally
support developments which improve the
accessibility attractiveness and
Recreation to these facilities this
application is current form doesn't do
that we can see from some of the
proposed buildings
um 6.26 on page 106 it also talks about
the councils producing a sports and
active physical activity strategy I
haven't seen that and come across us as
members
then you talk about the times of opening
which is 10 a.m to 10 p.m well when I
looked at the sunset times from April to
October the latest the sunset is 9 21 in
June and it goes down to October at 609
so maybe there'll be some anti-social
behavior issues with people going around
there and would they be there
um the conclusion in 3.2 it talked about
you can see the principle of development
for the mppf and there's no objection as
a raise that's obviously been discussed
tonight and again I think it's a
mishmash of items you just said Mr
salisbury's Ross is they're all about
the Victorian Park and the feel which is
the draw to half a million visitors a
year that we're getting already
um you've got an asset here the main
consideration in section five it talks
about uh the the main issue which
require consideration as part of
determination this application are the
principal development uh the impact
development on the carriage or an
appearance of the area well this would
know nothing to enhance the character
and appearance of the area it's
brilliant for when we have the markets
or when we have the armed forces and we
have things like that where we have
additions down there I think that's
really beneficial but if you if you're
putting these type of things in it
doesn't really serve many many um
peoples against strategy S1
it talks about uh on our bone policy S1
section 10. it talks about conserve and
enhance the historic environment and I
can't see that that does
5.2.3 policy E2 aims to support the
vision of retail office tourism and
culture and communities when I went and
read that in depth it talks about
in-town Center areas that's dictated on
page 70 of the local development plan
um there's a lot more as well there's a
lot more subjective nature of comments
that were basically in here and the
fourth bullet point which are again is
something that we can and this has been
recorded so we can go back on this
something that would support Council
Hood counselor and your good sales
proposal it says the prep Council The
Proposal would support local businesses
improve the offer within the park and
support the local economy I'd love to
see a business case for that because I'd
like to support more local businesses
with some form of access to the problem
they don't forget members we can they
can't have that now and they do modern
books comes down has a period of time
and then goes you know any business
could do that and that's within office
as delegated powers so there's no
problem about that as well
um finally
really the reasons for refusal
um again from from this
application there's several here you
could refuse on the grounds of not
meeting policies in one paragraph one M1
section four not reading the
requirements of of the the
um of of the camp project 16. that links
to M1 as well because that's a direct
linkage to that so it's um our own
policy S110 it fails to conserve or
enhance the historic environment
d1.1 it doesn't respect or enhance the
character of the area
and also D1 section A it doesn't
contribute or enhance so I think with
you know officers support
um if members I'd say we we reject this
and again it does then come back because
we require more detail and but first of
all the prom management plan needs to be
developed before we can look at any
multi site planning applications such as
this
and I went on a bit I know I'm sorry
okay
councilor Swain
um I didn't if I could simplify all that
um I would suggest we could
um refuse the application on the grounds
that we don't want any semi-permanent
use of those areas of the identified
areas
um
Council none well unless I've misread
the debate I don't think we're
suggesting that are we no I I mean I was
under the impression that we wanted to
go much more down the line of deferring
this application because we don't have
enough information on the table not
enough has been considered uh we have no
design plans wait well we've really got
nothing more than it's going to go here
here and here
um we don't know what will go where and
what those uh temporary
structures will look like not what they
might look like what they will look like
in every other plan we would know what
they look like in this plan
there is no guidance we've got well it
could be this it could be that it could
be that and I think I'd take on board
absolutely about the CO2 emissions
um so that was my understanding so I I
need a proposal from the floor that is
going to be seconded
so through you chair I think we need to
be clear about what our options are we
could improve this yes we could yes
um in line with the recommendation we
could refuse it yes on the grounds that
have been stated which Miss Matthews has
come up with we can't defer it we can't
refer it to another committee apart from
Full Council or District planning
is that what's being said yes and that
further information could be
the management punishment plan
sorry I'm not no chair than me I'm just
trying to be clear about what the
options are really that they are the
four options
um I am going to make a recommendation
that we defer this to come back to this
committee at a later date once we have a
management plan and a proper well
thought through strategy for this
development
seconded
all those in favor please show by hands
one two three four five six seven uh
unanimous
don't say anything
it's carried
this matter will be deferred
for more information to come back at a
later date
thank you
um that could that concludes
um our meeting this evening thank you
very much
um for your time
um I'd like to thank officers
um and one officer that's gone uh and
I'm closing the meeting at 8 45.